on est prêtes pour marcher ouais ouais
bah oui merci de la mer vue de loin
simple rencontre
rien qui ne sorte de l'ordinaire
maintenant ça fait plaisir ça fait aussi
du bien
cela enlève pull le tourbillon âge
mental tu bon nous on est seul on voyait
que les femmes ressentait vraiment le
besoin de rencontrer les intervenants
tant personne mais comme les contacts
physiques pour brésil isolement pour
recevoir conseils et renseignements au
delà du téléphone et des
visioconférences sont très limitées en
ces temps de pandémie
le centre ou qu'habitat coup-là singamas
travail a décidé de sortir dehors pour
aller vers les femmes est un endroit de
son choix donc ça peut être dans un parc
dans sa ruelle où elle se sent à l'aise
et en sécurité
donc on la rencontre dans cet espace là
où on offre de l'ecoute pour à peu près
une heure donc vraiment du soutien s'il
ya besoin de références - le juré porte
sud parce que moi j'ai des problèmes de
doute c'est j'ai juste un peu vulnérable
un endroit accessible sans que les
femmes n'aient à chercher leur chemin ou
apprendre des transports publics que
certaines préfèrent éviter en temps de
pandémie et la marche écoute peut
s'inscrire facilement dans une routine
sans attirer l'attention ni éveillé des
soupçons
on peut davantage parler de ce qu'on vit
à la maison qui peut être difficile
aussi haut niveau par exemple une femme
qui vit de la violence conjugale qui
peut pas s'absenter pour un longue
période de temps qu'on la rencontre dans
son espace proche de chez elle c'est à
travers le lien de confiance qu'on fait
avec elle à travers aussi nos
discussions donc on voit aussi que
souvent qu'il ya tel ou tel élément
caché derrière son isolement
écoutez pour détecter les risques
travailler en amont avant que les coups
ne pleuvent ou pin
la violence conjugale commence bien
avant qu'un incident de violence
physique puisse arriver
et là je parle par exemple à toutes les
situations où les femmes se retrouvent
dans des relations où elles sont
contrôlés et dominés par leurs
partenaires cette experte aimerait que
les comportements coercitif qui contrôle
en soient considérés comme des
infractions criminelles
ce qu'il nous faut ce serait comme
société a regardé les inégalités entre
les hommes et les femmes et comment dans
notre société on continue de normaliser
certains comportements alors qu'ils font
partie de la violence conjugale dans sa
démarche dead d'éducation populaire et
de prévention le centre des femmes d'ici
et d'ailleurs cherche à rejoindre des
femmes de toutes les origines
il a pignon sur rue dans villeray l'un
des quartiers montréalais les plus
diversifiées au plan ethnique culturelle
dont le taux de pauvreté est plus élevé
que la moyenne de la métropole je prends
l'exemple des femmes parrainer qu'elles
arrivent ici quelle est leur famille
dans leur pays donc parfois le seul
contact qu'elles ont que c'est leur
conjoint et souvent dans le cas par
exemple de violences conjugales il ya un
plus grand contrôle qui s'installe aussi
parce que les femmes ne connaissent pas
les ressources qui existent parmi les
obstacles à surmonter les barrières
linguistiques
les intervenantes du centre parle
plusieurs langues même si on est dans un
endroit public donc il reste que comme
il ya beaucoup de monde on garde un
certain anonymat aussi et la
confidentialité elle reste là bien sûr
souvent en marchant
les femmes se dévoile davantage
l'activité de marché coûte fonctionne
tellement bien que le centre compte la
poursuivre après la pandémie au besoin
c'est une bouffée d'air frais que pour
l'intervenante autant pour les femmes
quand on est chez nous je vois le
contenter
[Musique]